happy st patrick's how about it
happy st patrick's baby you can
you know it's it's uh
if you celebrate st patrick's
i want to wish you that wish you well
with it
if you've ever found yourself in a shiny
green hat
vomiting uh
outside of a 7-eleven
then you are probably
irish
if you've ever
if you hit about the age of 50 and you
have the same haircut as your wife
that's a that's an irish staple i feel
like
um what else
oh a lot of irish men and women as they
age they get the same tits on them
if you notice that
they sent they similarly jugged up
you know you see them they give they uh
that's a popular irish thing you hit 50
55 you and your
wife who's almost your buddy now
uh
you know they just they kind of morph
into the same being it seems like or
twins almost
and they they double titted they got the
same tits
but happy st patrick's day to you
um
what else a lot of closeted gay happens
during saint pets
because men they get the tights it's a
lot of liquor
they're carrying around the uh
in new orleans and the saint patrick's
day parade they'll carry this thing of
flowers
and then the men get drunk and they
start kissing each other on the face
even at some point
and i don't know at that point
i that's when i would usually drive home
but some men keep going and the parade
keeps going and
i don't know what happened i just
you know you just hope for the best for
those guys
you know you hope somebody gets them a
sandwich or kind of helps them
because you'll end up damn gay and not
even want to be you know and it wasn't a
plan when you started out in the morning
and that is uh st patrick's day a lot
what else um
oh dude i uh so the other day
i'm ordering
i guess what i want to talk about is
autism
you know i'm ordering some cottage
cheese at a uh breakfast place i'm
ordering some cottage cheese
and it's it you know it's a rare choice
it is what it is i ordered it
the guy goes uh
i don't know if we have cottage cheese
but let me see
what i can do for you
that's nice that's a sweet guy
so i wait he brings over a bowl he
brings over a bowl
and it's like
three or four pieces of cheese cut up in
a little bitty
squares and shapes kind of just
and he just kind of stacked them all in
a little bowl
and i i just i mean this [ __ ] just i'm
i'm grateful you know i didn't want
that's not how i didn't want things like
that but it the guy made an effort
but i think what we're starting to see
more and more is autism
you know we're starting to see it more
as a uh
it's a positive in this and because
here's what it is
a lot of big business owners now
you know uh jeff bezos
um elon musk
they have autism
you know nobody wants to flat out say it
but if you're part computer part person
that's always what autism was autism was
that you know
you know was danny calculator it was
that dude who you would start talking
you would reach out to shake his hand
and he would kind of shake he would
shake your hand with his eyes you know
he would like kind of just look look at
you look down look up look down look up
like he was [ __ ] you know he's part
computer
it's built into him
and those are people that are starting
to rule the world because the world is
becoming more man and more computer
it's mur you know we're emerging it's
that man you know it's that man pewter
you know
that compumen you know it's that um
it's that middle
ground you'll put a uh
you'll put your hand in a woman's pants
and she'll have a damn uh you know a
quarter of a keyboard down there
you know and you'll just start typing in
p you know [ __ ] or you know
labia or whatever however you spell it
you know you don't even you're not even
really touching the genitals anymore
you're just typing in the words of it
you know uh uh
you're just u-h-h-u-h-h-uh
until they you know
i'm just saying we're starting to we're
seeing the merging of people
and that's what you know it's just and
those are people that are going to rule
the world because it's
it's just we're becoming more of both
we're becoming more computerized
automated atm
blender
you know you just
so just being a human is not
it's good but it's old-fashioned
the these these people that are doing it
all now are people that can see both
worlds
at once
and sometimes you get the jeff bezos
sometimes you get the um
sometimes you get the elon musk
and sometimes uh you get patrick you get
the dude who brought me
who cut up four pieces of cheese into a
bowl
you know it's kind it's a light autism
it's not helping anybody really but
you know it it helps that you know it's
it it works at a diner a little bit
i guess
anyway um
i don't know exactly what i'm talking
about but i never have and uh and i'm
grateful to be here with you today
and uh i mean that
uh from all of my aortas let's uh let's
hear a little bit of this
[Music]
come on
we're gonna take it back baby
[Music]
i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could i be so far from my
home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up wearing spin
no
come on baby
yeah
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel like these leaves i must be
cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i found i can
feel it
[Music]
a little time
for me to set that parking brake
and let myself unwind
[Music]
[Music]
oh
there we are that's shine by bishop gunn
you know that
and that's that old hitter
and that's the
that's the one that started it off for
us
and here we are
384 383 episodes later
gang baby uh good to be with you today
what's going on not much man
not much really just kind of checking in
with myself you know
you know just sometimes i like to ask
myself well how are you feeling man
you know i do
you know i'm that fear you know
i'm that
that feeling ferret baby i'll scurry all
across my
damn you know i'll i'll just
you know i really i'm right there on my
feelings
if you need my feelings i got them
mentioned for you baby
um
yeah i like to ask myself what's going
on
what am i feeling what am i thinking
what's got me excited what's got me
scared
you know where's my head at
where should my head be at
i don't know
um
but i like to ask myself those things
what's going on
how are you feeling
and then answer myself well
sometimes i i don't want to answer
myself when i'm feeling good
some of my i'll get in that little
that spin cycle of uh
i just want to be feeling bad you know
that permanent pressure
um
but sometimes it's like hey
mama i
i'm all right baby
i just got four pieces of cheese cut up
in a small bowl son
you know i'm doing good
i just met a girl she's got
uh
she's got two
keyboard titties it's you know
i'm living i'm i'm [ __ ] in the future
i'm doing good
we're emerging i wonder are we becoming
more robots
you know you see these people that have
the
that have you know
half a calculator behind their eyes and
and uh
and they're more
uh operating system than they are heart
and you what you're like you know you
start to wonder are they
the next evolution
am i just out here living in the stone
age
with my feelings
when three generations from now it'll be
you know it'll all you know
they'll have our feelings almost
well we've been taken over by some type
of
or crossbred with a gigabyte and
and uh
and you'll press a button on your hip
and you'll smile
you know it i just i don't i don't know
what the future's gonna be like i don't
know
but i believe that autism is that gray
area where we're starting to see maybe
because it used to be somebody at all
telling me like damn ricky's [ __ ] up
you know
oh damn ricky's over there licking that
snake
ricky's licking snakes
but now
you're like damn
you know
ricky's licking snakes
and uh
and he's running a damn app
you know he owns four apps so you're
like well he's really
he's doing well you know
he started a damn petco on his phone
all but you know where he started
selling leather goods because he learned
of you know
he just tasted that texture for so long
on the back of that rattler and next
thing you know
he's out here vending damn purses you
know fendi purses or something
you know uh
you know he's out here you know making
milk snake uh
um
you know he's out here making milk snake
sand skin sandals
for deaf children or whatever and he's
you know he won an uh academy award or
whatever
and he's got autism i'm just saying i
don't know i don't know anything
and i never have so
um
what's going on i'm trying to think of
what else is going on not much i'ma go i
saw some uh music the other day went and
watched some singer songwriters um
[Music]
i'm enjoying my time out here in the
central east right now
um
march madness is here
dude i love march madness
i love it i love watching the games
you know basketball starts at like 10
a.m
god i love that
i love that
you know i love that you can kind of be
at work but you you know
you're cheering on colleges you never
even heard bellarmine
colgate uh
ithaca you know
um
you know westwego state or whatever
gulf coast community college tech
sunday school
go ravens you know you're just you don't
even know what's going on you're buying
merch and [ __ ] you know it's just you're
dialed in and there's just great
basketball all week
and i love that
um
yo what's going on i'm gonna get myself
a piano
my birthday's coming up i'm gonna get
myself a piano
um i'm looking forward to that
you know i've wanted a piano for a long
time so i'm gonna have that [ __ ]
uh
and yeah that's kind of what's happening
in my week really
um
yeah i got up this morning and uh
i went over to the gym you know i get up
and do a routine right now
i get up
and i make a
uh i do prayers and then i do a
gratitude list and a meditation
um
and then i get into motion
i get moving baby i get you know
weiner first is kind of my motto it's
like
sometimes you can walk where your body
your shoulders are first or your face is
first
we used to have this one fella he always
kind of looked like this like his nose
was always first
looked like he was always uh smelling
booty you know body gas or something
or sniffing you know that butt hash that
if you know if somebody had been you
know
chiefing out their own butt doing gas
body gas and fighting
you know
fighting
if somebody been doing any of that he uh
you dumb
he walked like he had nose first you
know this fella stephen
like he was always like he was a
detective for uh
body gas poop gas
but butt hash you know what i'm talking
about gas bottom
and um
and uh so some people walk like that
nose first
some people walk knees first a lot of
indian people
if you have if you have a friend who is
in a uh
uh far eastern indian
not native americans
who are pretty much my new favorite
people too i want to say that
so
uh
but anyway if you are a uh indian
you know like
you know what i'm talking about an
indian dude trucker
or
gas station guy i.t guy engineer
uh
sometimes they almost look like black
guys but they're not you ever see a you
see a black do you but he has regular
hair you're like what the [ __ ] that's an
indian dude or bangladeshi
and they won't tell you if they're one
of the other you gotta ask them you
almost have to tap on them and ask them
and indian people
they walk sometimes knees first
it's hard it's very
they do they will do it
but in my new thing weiner first if you
got that wiener if you are leading
with that vestibule of seed baby that
weiner
and then you you telling the world hey
get this dad you know
that's what you're telling the world
you're saying hey you gonna come at me
i'm gonna give you this serving right up
and there's something powerful about
that
to walk with your loin with that bag
baby
you know with that bag and branch baby
with that bat with that batting satchel
baby you know what i'm saying
with that root
and them seed buckets baby there's
something powerful to say you know what
i'm putting it all forward
there's something powerful about that
oh
and native americans did that
they walked they're very the posture is
right there
you got snout genital knee and that [ __ ]
was lined up and maybe you see that the
penis would be just ahead just winning
the race you know like they're coming at
us like twistedness in their nose and
it's nice and they see the faintness and
the synonymy
penis
you know uh
and there's something powerful about
that
and i'm 1 8 pontiac a lot of people
didn't know that
i am 1 8 pontiac we got the chart back
or whatever
somebody spitting something you know
or my sister banged somebody and they
got tested i don't know what happened
but i am 1 8 pontiac and i'm happy about
that
uh we got some great calls that came in
um
you know i want to let you know also
right now that uh we're currently uh
uh actually you know what let's go to
this call that came in
right here
oh what's up phil my name is uh victor i
actually saw you in the uh
in chicago i'm from chicago i saw you at
the chicago theater
oh
what's up victor
and victor is a great name because it's
uh
it means champion
it means first place leader trophy boy
you know what i'm saying that blue
ribbon monster
that's victor baby
that's victor
onward
i was a tall mexican with blue sweater i
don't know
oh i did meet a tall mexican after the
show
um
and they're rare i mean when you meet
them you know it
i mean you damn want to steal a piece of
their hair you know because it's
they're
that's that chupacabra baby you know
what i'm saying you don't see a tall
mexican
name 44 tall mexicans
you know what i'm saying
is this they don't have it
and they're trying
you see a lot of mexican people these
days they [ __ ] upward
you see them meet somebody and if
they're not 5'4 they're not [ __ ] them
and i'm sorry about my language but
that's just what's going on baby
let's hear the call
same thing uh i was wondering what you
think about you know them ukrainian
brothers you know
getting getting absolutely [ __ ]
blacked by russia you know you know what
i'm saying
and uh what do you think about the
president of ukraine
uh denying a right out he said i don't
need to run out i mean bullets bro i
think this guy's [ __ ] thinking huge
bro like this guy [ __ ] man you know
look baby i'll say this
they're bangers baby the ukrainians are
bangers and those people man
those frozen far easterners baby they
about that they about that bout
them people like to cigarette smoke
and uh
and try and knock each other out bro
it is a ice cold culture
they have i remember seeing uh
not seeing but hearing descriptive
stories of children playing with stone
dolls over there
and you'd see a drawing of like a
five-year-old girl carrying a you know
four pound uh
stone doll that she got for christmas or
whatever
so
when you when you when your first
baby doll that [ __ ] weighs four pounds
and it's made out of stone and you got
to keep you keep it in your bed at night
or even if you put it in the garden and
a bird shits on that thing baby that's a
and you still carrying that thing to
church i mean you were
a lot of tough people over there um
and yeah you know i think it's a you
know
it's kind of a travesty to see that
there's so much
violence
uh
but yeah they want to ease wit it out
they want to bang it out that dude's
saying mail me a bullet you could put a
bullet in the mail of that dude he's
ready to use it
um
and you know i don't know enough about
the situation uh
but i just know that we're going to try
to help where we can and actually right
now uh we're running a 25 off sale on
the out of gas collection
from now until this sunday march 20th
and proceeds from the sale will go to
the world vision international
ukraine crisis fund
i have a friend that works for that
organization they're a great
organization
they really focus on helping
children
and they have this ukraine specific
crisis fund so that's where it's going
to go to if you don't like that charity
that's totally fine uh put your efforts
somewhere else we're going to make a
donation as well um
well that's what we're going to do man
you know and uh
yeah it's just i mean war is just damn
it's just people want it all you know
you see people they want it all
and i think putin he don't he wants to
go out he wants to go out that banger
you know he's kind of that fifth year
senior right now
and he's like i'm not going out without
using all the toys
i'm not going out without using all the
toys he's that toy bear you know
and he opens up his uh
toy chest and it's all missiles baby
it's missiles and strong knifes
he's got a knife that have a damn
missile in it you stab somebody and then
a missile shoots him like damn
just stabbed him
but that's who he is baby that's who he
is and he is who you thought he was you
always knew it
the dude's shirtless he's out there
[ __ ] you know he's
you know he's he don't have a lot of
heart
and he's from another era
but ukraine's saying let's bang baby
let's make it three out of five you know
herb dean's trying to step in and
they're saying nah nah nah nah let it go
let it go i'd love to see bisping and
anik
uh commentate it
because i wouldn't be surprised to see
ukraine make that comeback and um
you know and our thoughts and well
wishes and prayers with everybody over
there it's a lot of travesty going on
when you see war happen
and in a second we're going to take
those calls uh we had a lot of people
call in about the masturbation
and if they had ever had a sibling
uh if they'd called a sibling
masturbating how that it fared
um and what that's like
to grow up being a victim of um
of visual sibling masturbation
seeing
victim so
all right i want to know uh what would
you do if you didn't have any high
interest loans
and it's a good question because some
people don't know
some people they might make themselves a
steak dinner
or get get a steak for the kid a kid had
never had a steak
i remember i had my first steak when i
think i was 16 17. somebody daddy cut me
a piece of steak or left some on his
plate because he got drunk
and i ate it
well what would you do
if you didn't have high interest loans
or credit card debt would you move to a
new city would you start a family or a
new family a lot of men do that
through upstart you can pay off your
existing debt quickly
with a personal loan that's right
so you can tackle your next big
financial goal if you want to start a
fishing camp or if you want to adopt a
child
whether it's paying off credit credit
cards consolidating high interest debt
or funding personal expenses over a
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date
upstart knows you're more than just your
credit score
so rather than looking at your credit
score alone upstarts model considers
other factors like your income
employment and other information
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com
t-h-e-o that's up start
u-p-s-t-a-r-t dot com
slash theo don't forget to use our url
to let them know that we sent you loan
amounts will be determined based on your
credit
income and certain other information
providing your own application go to
upstart.com
[Music]
you gotta if you need help you gotta get
it
they'll offer it a lot of times loans
will offer it
i wanna tell you about all the birds
and i'm not talking about uh gulls and
uh
pelicans and everything toucan
and sparrow
talk about the shoes man
you want to feel your feet
fly put on the new all birds
tree dasher 2.
i love my all birds i love them when i
go to the airport i put them on
you know if i'm going to a casual
business meeting
which a lot of business meetings are now
and they're casual or semi-casual i
think
um then that's how you do it
you know and i don't know what
semi-casual means it might mean you have
a little bit of an erection
but i don't know that and don't quote me
on that but you can quote me that the
all birds tree dasher 2
is a great shoe
um
and it's it's a running shoe now you
know i i i've frequented the uh the
casual pairs
but the running shoe is different it's
for outdoors it's for taking on your
goals out there in the spring
and feeling and letting nature say hey
i'll meet you
outdoors i'll meet you halfway mother
nature let's go for a jog their light
more responsive foam adds spring to
every step
extra traction grips the pavement
they have fsc certified tensile
cell
that's right eucalyptus tree fiber built
into them dang
so you just if you're running on a trail
you're putting nature on nature baby
shoelaces made from recycled plastic
bottles go to
allbirds.com the new all birds tree
dasher two i love my all birds i really
do and you will too
yeah we had this call that came in um
i want to play this sucker
hey ceo
my name is big daddy jay
big daddy jay brother
and uh appreciate your call man
onward
i'm calling all the way from
walnut california run upon yeah
walnut
and uh
so you know it's not that walnut is a
nut you don't hear much about peanut
really have a lot of the
they kind of
they got a lot of the acreage
walnut
it's kind of that all you know it's kind
of that unorthodox strain looking nut
it looks like a damn nut out of your
body a body nut
you know a sack nut
uh
that little seed baby it looks like a
real body nut
but yeah uh
anyway i don't know what i'm talking
about homework
hey man i just wanted to say i love the
podcast
uh i love the comedy specials you got on
netflix they're hilarious
um and i wanted to ask you uh if you
don't mind blowing up the spot
uh what's the name of the ayahuasca
retreat that you went to in la um
and i've been i've been feeling a need
to go and get that done
gang baby i appreciate you asking and
it's a secretive place that's the that's
the thing right now
you know it can't be legally done in
america
i believe unless you're a church
um
let me see it says right here the
ayahuasca plan itself is not illegal in
the united states however the active
ingredient dmt is as it is classified as
a schedule one drug which is the same
category as heron and ecstasy man
i can tell you these things are way
ayahuasca is way different than that
ayahuasca has been decriminalized in
oakland california santa cruz
uh denver colorado washington dc and
cambridge massachusetts this means you
won't face prosecution if you possess or
use the psychedelic brew
but only in these cities
uh and i don't know how much of that is
true i don't know if that's really the
best information this is just off a
random
uh
space on the internet let me read one
more
um
while it is true that only the two main
brazilian ayahuasca religions
unai o do vegetal
and
daime have secured legal protections for
sacramental ayahuasca use in the u.s
and those legal protections do not yet
formally extend to anyone else
today there is a growing movement of
churches asserting their rights either
by formal petitions or heel digging
perseverance to use psychedelic
sacraments as part of the free exercise
of their religions under the first
amendment of the u.s constitution
and the religious freedom restoration
act
um
that's really interesting
this article is also from 2020 so that
doesn't really help us
let me see if i can get anything more
recent
seattle's psychedelic revolution has
arrived decriminalization means shrooms
have officially taken root
oh interesting
um
you know i'm gonna have to do a little
bit more uh investigative on this
i'm gonna have to do a little bit more
investigator from what i know what from
what i believe
and have heard you have to be a church
to
administer the drug
you have to be a church
i know there's a lot of groups that are
fighting and pushing for it the group
that i did it with is fighting and
and pushing for it
but in the meantime it's a
it's got a trap house vibe to it
and it's it's really fascinating you go
and you wear all white and you sit there
and you are in this
group
and i didn't know anybody when i went
and uh
you drink one plant and then a little
while later you drink another plant
and you sit there
and you just start like meditating
you just start having a thought and then
it becomes a story
and then
uh
the story
you start to realize that it's not just
a thought you're having
it's a uh
sometimes kind of a realization
um
i don't know i'll go more into it i'm
going to think more about it um
if you have any questions about the
ayahuasca send in or about my experience
send them in and i'll try to do an
episode about it
specifically about it next time
i know last time we put this question on
it was a very interesting question as to
the the time in men's life
about their body and their
semen
and i want to uh just hear that question
right now here it is
i'm sure there's probably if there's
anybody out there if you ever had a
brother you accidentally seen your
brother masturbate or something
you know and i'm not trying to be
you know nasty or whatever but i'm just
curious the effect it has on you can you
still
look at him the same as everything's
still okay between you uh
and if you saw him do you tell him
you let him know that or is that a
private thing and
you know or if or if your brother saw
you how did you handle that
you know how did you handle that
and we had a lot of interesting calls
man and i find this stuff to be
fascinating
and some you know
some people will say uh
this stuff's homoerotic i don't find
that
but i find it interesting to get a bead
on
how we learn sex
and what it means and how we
you know i've had taboos at things in my
life where i was like oh i can't talk
about this i can't share this i can't
say things that i'm into or not into i'm
afraid
um
i've always had an intense nervousness
around sex
uh
so
it's always felt like it's just a crazy
game a freeze tag where it's just like
you're it you're it you're it you're it
you're it you're you're you're you're it
it you know it's like um
i don't know i've never handled it super
well
i get so damn excited i'm like one of
those uh fainting goats you know
i'm like one of those fainting goats
baby when it comes to this the sexual
and the full sexual baby i got that
faint and goat energy
you know i'm saying i'll be in there
i'll be bleating and hammering and i'll
be eating garbage
you know i'm that goat but damn son
before i know it a couple uh
thrusts in and that the clock strikes
midnight and i'm
i'm faint you know i faint i'll you know
i get my energy gets so heightened up i
can't handle it and my brain shuts down
but anyway let's get back to you guys
sorry i'm hogging all this
uh that was the question and you guys
had some great uh great calls that came
in man i want to hear a couple of them
here we go
gang gang theo this is zach what's going
on man zach
and that's short usually for zechariah i
believe
or uh zack
z-a-c-h zach maybe even
i think it's
uh
somewhere from somewhere else so let's
hear it
um
listening to your episode the other day
and you're talking about you know
learning to beat off and stuff and uh
and getting like caught by your brother
or whatever now i never got caught by a
family member but i got taught by a
fellow down the street from me and he
taught me what masturbation was and then
um
you know back in middle school and when
you were figuring that out
and all the homies found how you know we
all found out together how to beat off
you know one guy learned he started
telling everybody like yo you got to try
this [ __ ] and the next thing you know
bro it's a friday night we're having a
sleepover and we're all hanging out
watching some freaking pornography
together just beating off oh yeah
the devil's video game baby
you know that little spunk bowser you
know what i'm talking about
fighting that damn inner enemy
onward
it's a bunch of freaking 12 year old
dudes just getting there i mean
nothing's coming out we couldn't come
yet but you know we were trying
um
anyway looking gay or nothing is just
you know your boys found out how to beat
off you're like dude this shit's sick
um anyways bro love the podcast love you
man
gang baby this shit's sick bro
dang
bruh we were at randalls
and we were beaten
yeah baby i feel look it's i mean it's
all interesting how does it come into
your life how do you learn it
is it in a comfortable space is it an
uncomfortable space i'm sure if you and
all your friends are out there just
driving you know you know
beating but not even saying it not even
you know just like the damn blue man
group out there you know you guys are
doing you know you're putting in the
work but nobody's
you don't really know you know you're
not
you just
y'all ain't getting nothing out that's a
damn blue man group
hell that could have been how the blue
man group started couple dudes beaten
and there's no you know no geyser and
you know no spout and the next thing you
know that damn turn blue and they start
a band
um
yeah i think look i of course it's
nothing gay to nobody unless there's a
gay dude who was in the group
if that's the case then that is his
he bro he saved the sheets that guy
if you have a friend who isn't married
and he's never had a girlfriend and
he wears a bed sheet every halloween
with the eyes cut out
and it's the same bed sheet then that
dude is us that dude was an undercover
gay dude who was in y'all's friend group
because he's probably he probably
started taking art classes he's drawing
the reenact drawing those scenes i mean
to him that's everything
but yeah it's interesting how do you
learn it
i remember somebody uh
at school one time said the word dildo
and i didn't know what it was
you know and i knew a lot of words i was
a word boy
people you'd see me sometime running
down the street a damn preposition fall
out of my bag
or an ing or a you know
led or a damn
you know uh
you know you'd see a damn animated pia
just roll you know
fall out of my shirt sleeve or something
i was a word boy
and uh
and man yeah you see um
no i don't know
but that's one way look
i think that's insane to see people just
using a damn air rifle to some of y'all
you know
that's insane to me but
that's how you learned it
i mean i remember i
i had
um
[Music]
i had found some nudie magazines
titty literature
you know what i'm talking about titty
literature baby
you know
and uh
and i found him on the top level of my
brother's closet
and dude i got out there at the same
time i found a little bit of a lazy
liquor
and that [ __ ] was peach peach flavored
or something something beautiful
beautiful flavor you know a flavor they
didn't have a lot of flavor back then
you had peppermint yet strawberry
yeah lime had just come out and people
were all crazy about lime you know
you'd see husband you know spousal
killing somebody choked the spouse to
death he wouldn't share the lime you
know he was he kept the lime in his
truck you know so when peach came out
people were [ __ ] keyed up
you'd see people caught keying each
other's cars and yelling you're a [ __ ]
out of their vehicle when they're
driving by and [ __ ] people didn't know
how to handle the energy
because nobody had seen peach before as
a new flavor
and damn when it hit the scene people
were gassed up
and uh i got up on that it was the top
level in my brother's closet and they
had some nudie magazine and some liquor
and i'd never had nail one of them bro
and i crack open one and i crack open
the other
and next thing you know i'm you know
touching myself to the magazine and
sipping on the liquor
and then i'm sipping on
one point i'm sipping on the magazine
dude i'm trying to pour the titties into
my mouth and i'm touching the bottle
i just got all damn confused and then at
one point i blacked out and fell off
that shelving unit
you know like a damn you know i fell off
a child i landed a man baby
and i was blacked out unconscious
erect and had liquor uh peach liquor on
my breath
amen baby that's all i gotta say
let's take another call you guys had
some great ones the hotline as always is
985-664-9500
onward
hey this is uh stevie thing calling out
of new jersey
stevie d
out of new jersey
and some people can't even spell their
last name and that you know and i'm not
saying that that's sad stevie i just
you know we're here for you bubby stevie
d thank you brother onward
just calling to
tell you what it's like to have your
brother
walk in on you uh you know jerking it
not only did my brother
catch me jerking this but also
my sister and my mother did as well
not at the same time
although i think that might have
actually been better
but yeah anyways uh it's [ __ ]
horrible it's exactly how you would
imagine it
you know it ruins not only that day but
a week
possibly 10 days of your life
just feels pure shame
you know your brother tries to pretend
everything's okay but you know it isn't
oh yeah i mean your brothers know you
know
he's no uh
you know
benedict cumberbatch or whatever he's no
uh brad paisley he's not a great actor
so he can try to pretend all he wants
that everything's fine but it's
the reality is seeping through the seams
that he knows that you are
you know touching your body in such a
unique way that semen's coming out of it
and that is
that's a lot man it sounds like a lot
anyway onward
my mom was probably the worst though
because she walked in and i was just
sitting on a bed
staring at a laptop naked
sitting there crisscrossed applesauce oh
native american style
now you got to respect that a little
you know i'm one-eighth pontiac baby and
you gotta respect a man who gets back to
his roots to
get back to his
roots onward
and you know it really just uh made me
take a good look at my life
but yeah it's it's exactly as bad as you
would imagine it oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah i can imagine i that
i can see when all the family sees it
when all the family gets the hang of
that uh when they all get to and then
they're talking you know they're talking
about it
you know they're going to the movies and
after the movie they're walking to the
car and one of them's like oh
you know
remember when uh
hey this is uh stevie t
remember when stevie d bur you know was
bursting himself over there
you know and then the other one's like
oh he was bursting himself by me you
know
so yeah i'm sure
that they have had a real hoot now i'm
sure you've given him a lot of joy
now at the time very traumatic
especially your sister and mother to see
it i mean don't you i want you to lock a
door i don't you know how to damn close
the door
what do you you know
and who sits there if in native american
i mean i guess i pre you know
you know i'm sorry i'm really judging
here but i just you know i just
well here's what i would do i think you
should at one make make some joy out of
it now i would have them all bring a
score card to the table one day
y'all are at dinner you have dessert
have a pudding
have a pudding
and be like look guys on the count of
three i want you to all rate me on how
you felt like i was doing as a
masturbator
then they all hold that card up you get
a nine you get a six if your sister
gives you a ten dude then you guys
that then
then then that's on her now
if your sister gives you a damn 10 on uh
on turbine
that's on her
so i think uh but that would add some
levity to it and really bring it off
that high cliff of
you know uh stevie dee's a perv you know
stevie dang he's a parent
all right let's uh let's get in another
one here right here
homeward
what's up baby bear this is john from
sunny la i'm just looking out my
balcony enjoying a cup of coffee and i'm
responding to the
brothers and masturbation
question that you have
what's up john thank you for calling man
from los angeles and we appreciate you
and if you're drinking coffee and you're
looking out the window you almost be
damn rich baby
if you got a window in a french press
son damn
y'all must be damn rich your daddy must
have damn done something huh
let's hear more
my brother actually taught me how to
masturbate and uh we're best of friends
man
i think i was like
11 we shared a room and he uh
he was awake and woke me up and he's
messing around and i'm like yo tony what
are you doing
he looked at me man he said i'm
masturbating it feels so good you've
never masturbated damn tony huh
homer
[Music]
i don't even know what that is man
so right next to him he sat me down
and taught me and being 11 man with
those boners i couldn't get enough of it
i was going into school
i was like i'd sneeze and i'd crack a
boner i can't believe riley doesn't
riley doesn't he's got to be walking
around full tilt baby
yeah i mean look riley mal's a
homeschooled kid and who knows what
happened now and who knows what god
wants for him or if his parents are
you know trying to detour him off of
god's bust path i don't
know you know this is fascinating to me
that your brother
it is fascinating to me that your
brother taught you how to masturbate i'd
never
i've never heard of that
um and at first i'm thinking man this
guy's this is this is
this is not good
but then the more i'm thinking about it
i'm like this is
this is
maybe this is how it's supposed to be
you know because otherwise who teaches
you
you know some creep over there some guy
selling sugar syrup or whatever
you know some guys got you in his truck
or something he's a trucker he drove off
the interstate he's putting tootsie
rolls in you and michael grutsch's mouth
and now he you know
and now y'all all dampened up over there
y'all you know and you don't even know
anybody
um
maybe it's the brother's responsibility
maybe it's the brother's responsibility
or the father's responsibility
that's a great i wonder how they used to
do it in native culture
because that's where we're missed we're
missing all of literally all of these
beats you know like
we're missing this connective tissue
that
we allow everything to be made taboo and
then
we
and then it's profited off of products
are created it's like
if my brother taught me how to
masturbate i
i use the same style as him you know
it's like people would know us by our
style if you know say a cop saw somebody
jerking off near a building and they
just see the shadow they could oh that's
that you know that's how their fa that's
the family
style you know i mean i just
that's fascinating man
you know i i think a good response on
this what do you guys think 985-664-9503
is it a brother is that a good idea it's
a brother's responsibility
to teach their younger sibling
how to masturbate
the father might not be because that's
but i don't know
yeah i don't it's not
you don't
do it to him but you
i don't know i have somebody's father
taught them i don't know some of this is
just really interesting to me man
you know i learned from a magazine and
then i found a dirty movie and i put
that [ __ ] in and next thing you know
i'd ejaculated and i felt horrible i
didn't know what was going on
and i felt ashamed there was nobody i
could ask my dad couldn't even hear me
i remember he was 82 or 83.
and i tried to ask him something and his
[ __ ] heart pressure went up and he
all he couldn't drive his car
and i remember he pulled the car over
and i thought he was so sad that i'd
asked him
and it had nothing to do with it he was
just senior citizen and just
had decided he couldn't drive anymore
and i'm just sitting there and
i just i don't know just a lot of bad
[ __ ] but um
anyway his brother taught him there you
go that's one way to do it
all right we're going to get to a few
more i want to also let you know
that uh
mint mobile
switching to mint mobile is the easiest
way to save this year yes it is
as the first company to sell premium
wireless service only
mint mobile lets you maximize your
savings with plans starting at just 15
bucks a month that's it
you want to cut down
you don't need the brook and mortal
store they can do it
for people looking for extra savings
meant mobile
yep premium wireless choose the amount
of monthly data that's right for you
stop paying for data you never use
switch to mint mobile
yep just 15 bucks a month
uh you could be saving money i mean my
bill is 270 a month
so again this is to save 255 dollars
could be uh
that's astronomical
to get your new wireless plan for just
15 bucks a month and get the plan
shipped to your door for free
they have unlimited talk and text and
high speed data unlimited talking text
and high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network use your own
phone along with any mint mobile plan
keep your same number
to get your own new wireless plan for
just 15 bucks a month go to mint
dot com slash t-h-e-o
that's m-i-n-t
m-o-b-i-l-e dot com slash theo
cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a
month at
mintmobile.com slash t-h-e-o
and if you're looking for health you're
looking to change things that's a tough
thing
you know i noticed sometimes for me it's
like i got to change the gym i got to
change the place i'm going i got to
change the music i listen to i gotta
change the activity i'm doing well
somebody that can help you do all of
that
is peloton that's right peloton is
stepping into the ring
with new
disciplines new offerings
adding to their lineup which of these
new additions sounds good to you boxing
discover a fast furious and fun workout
with peloton instructors in your corner
and that's one thing you access these
instructors you access the new platforms
another thing you can access is the new
artist series music selections
peloton is adding fun new artist series
classes from pop and rock
to hip hop and edm if you want that
there are over 100 artists series to
choose from
find your favorite music and turn your
new workout into a concert
also more daily workout variety
it's easier than ever to stick to your
goals when your workouts
are interesting
that's right 20 minutes of cardio do a
15-minute total body class workout or 30
minutes of strength there are so many
options go to one peloton dot com to
learn more that's o-n-e
p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com
okay let's uh venture into a few more of
these interesting here when we do stuff
about sex and net
embody sex
okay here we go
yo what up fio gang gang it's your boy
jeff i coming to you from long island
new york
jeff i
and that's a rare name baby
i is a unique last name there's a
fighter jessica i
a uh ufc fighter beautiful and tough
gang onward
i just want to let you know that i'm a
huge fan and you're a huge inspiration
to me
i'm actually having my son may 25th and
i'm actually in ceo
the name is definitely
derived from the huge inspiration of you
and i just wanted to say that
you've had a huge impact on me and my
life and
i thank you for everything you've done
for me over these past couple years
man thank you
that's very that's very awesome that's
exciting uh
you know i feel
uh
that's very sweet of you man i
appreciate it and i'm happy and excited
for you guys and your child
that's beautiful man yeah i got a little
son and theo it's a good name
you know um
um
i'm just happy for you
onward but um yeah one crazy [ __ ]
story um
just cut down the center most recent
podcast
um teenage easter
my little brother he's 13 now so we have
a pretty decent age gap i'm 25 going on
26 and a couple weeks ago when he was
sleeping over my house
he left his phone open and now i'm not
the type of person to invade anyone's
privacy but
it was literally open on his browser
history so just out of curiosity i
peeped it
okay
onward
and i was definitely [ __ ] scarred for
life i felt like i had to wash my
eyeballs out with clorox bleach after i
saw his history man
i
mean categories from slam and granny and
the fannie
to foot jobs
to double penetration dildo rides man oh
my god i just i just don't see how a 13
year old
is you know
interested in something like this you
know i'm just a simple guy it's like the
big booty you know some big tits
categories but
i just want to know your thoughts on um
these young and uh getting access to um
pornographic uh
videography
yeah
oh well it's heartbreaking
you know
i mean it's heartbreaking to see that
these youngsters are all porned out
you know the category it's just too
intense now
when i was young the categories were
different it was like uh
you know uh
tits across the street
you know or like uh
you know chick with cough and big tits
you know that would be
you know or two two chicks with a call
you know women coughing women with tits
you're like oh this is gonna be good you
know her lawyer's wife
or um
woman with asthma with you know
with tits you know or um
or woman chasing squirrel with uh with
strong labia
you know it was just a different time
it was a different time
and now the levels of pornography out
there it's in you know it's insane
you know woman [ __ ] building you know
and you're like whoa whoa
that thing's three stories you know damn
you know that thing's got a car
dealership in the bottom i mean is she
gonna be okay you know it's just there's
a lot more health concerns out there now
and to know that the young bucks are
seeing it man i don't know
i don't know i don't know if it's okay i
don't know if it's safe
so that you know it's just a different
time now
i mean i remember we had
when we learned about teddy you know uh
we had a fella that had soft hands i
mean just
so soft you know looks like his hands
were just probably 40
um
polyester
and he just had the softest hands and i
remember we would get him to put his
hands like this
and to get a a pencil half a pencil and
get the eraser sticking
out and he'd do that after school
with that eraser sticking out
and you'd go over and you'd feel on his
hand on the on the
was a nipple
and one of your other buddies who was in
choir he would whisper titty in your ear
you know
so
it was just it was like this perfect
storm you could feel this soft
kind of nipple thing and he's saying
titty and you got this
just this robust sense of femin you know
of of a breast
and that was porn
you know we had all meet up it was just
joining four it was just you know
and now it's just
i mean you know
there's just no god in it at least we
were together and there was a little bit
of unity and you had to you know get a
pencil
yeah that i mean that was all it took
for arousal for us
and now though now the waters are deep
the waters are deep and the waters are
devilish
you know and
and sometimes you need god's help man i
would maybe maybe take your brother over
to the church
you know and i'm not saying beat his ass
at church but
you know maybe get out the car
and
hit him once and see if god wants you to
hit him again you'll know immediately
because sometimes the older sibling has
to come in
and be god's hit man
you know sometimes the older sibling has
to come in and be god's hit man because
if not what's next for the boy
you gotta ask yourself that and when i
say you have to you have to you're the
brother man
but dang
and also i don't want him teaching a
little theo that's me now i'm and now
i'm in
i don't want him teaching me this [ __ ]
you know
nine years from now his little net you
know my uncle
is gonna be
you know he's gonna be you know
what's he gonna teach me you know it's
just i don't
what's he gonna get me for easter or
whatever i don't need all that [ __ ] i'm
only nine
so
just take care of us man take care of us
and uh and congratulations on the new
kiddo man i'm excited for you guys baby
gang gang
oh man we got one more call right here
hey siobhan this is uh tyrell
i'm uh
just driving home back in california and
i was listening to your podcast thought
i'd get some uh some stuff off my chest
tyrell baby thank you for calling man
and it's good to get some uh
diversity on the pod baby we love you
guys dude and we know you are good
folks onward
just driving home back to california and
i was listening to your podcast thought
i'd get uh some stuff off my chest you
know i've been single for quite some
time now i've been having sex in the
last
i don't know two years and i i just need
some some advice man on
how do i get back in the game how do i
you know
get my
my willy wet if you will um appreciate
it love what you're doing keep it up
later
gang baby you trying to get that hitter
baby
and i feel you look first of all you
gotta get a woman or something that has
you know
something that's willing to let you
[Music]
get inside it
and legally i think it has to be a woman
or man but i would you know i don't know
where you reside on the sexual spectrum
um
but
it has to be one of them
so
i don't know how to get back out there
are you dating did you give me any more
information let me listen one more time
off my chest you know i've been single
for quite some time now i've been having
sex in the last
i don't know two years
okay now that's a long time and there's
a lot of asexuality going on so
you know
but sometimes you go through patches and
you don't need to feel like you have to
have sex all the time that's something
that's crazy
you know that's a crazy thing
because once you start that fuse inside
of yourself like i got a hell i got to
get i got to meet girl girl girl dude
that [ __ ] got lit in me years ago and
that thing is a nightmare
and mine's finally starting to quell a
little
so i don't feel that constant need like
i need approval
um
because that fuse will get lit and it
will just keep going and it's not even
you you're just acting on this impulse
so first of all you're coming from a
great place of peace
i'm choosing i would like to get
that damp baby that labia you know what
i'm saying bro that little smut mitten
dog you know what i'm saying bro that's
not holster
so
i think you got a great shot dude i
don't know how to just get back in just
to sex
i think it's kind of easy people are
doing sex all the time
even though i read an article that
animals aren't even having sex anymore
so that's i don't know what that's going
to be like in the future
you know you go to pet stores and
there's just videos and [ __ ] and just
reenactments in there of just
our little
stuffed animals i have no i you know
a lot of scary stuff going on but if you
have any suggestions for tyrell how to
just get sex i mean go get you a little
hooker
also if you want that i guess i don't
know enough to know what you want
um
but if you just want to get the willy
wet
then yeah i think you could you know
you could go to another country and get
you a little hooker
uh
you know that titty for hire baby you
could do it or talk to somebody there's
a lot of women out there these days who
are open to sex just to help help
somebody out
um
but i don't know if you have a
suggestion for tyler2 you can hit the
hotline 985-664-9503
uh
and that's a good
those are both interesting things
that
are going on
but yeah how to just get some sex damn
just you know i i look i bet if you ask
40 women two of them will say yeah
a lot of people don't care you know that
sex isn't as
important to them or that just not as
much of a
hang up for him
so and i haven't seen a picture of you
or a drawing of you
so i don't know much about you but
you sound like somebody that somebody
would [ __ ]
to be real honest let me listen again
real quick
i've been having sex in the last
i don't know two years and i i just need
some some advice now
yeah you're driving across california
you can drive you can talk and drive on
the phone at the same time
somebody will [ __ ] you bro i think
yeah
somebody will for sure dude
so i think just stay active man stay
alive
if somebody has a great suggestion for
tyler you can also offer for tyrell
sorry brother
um
985-664-9503
damn will wade got fired lsu basketball
coach i broke my heart
uh
okay um
what's going on with me
i'm good
you know a lot some some stuff on the
personal side we'll get into it on
another episode you know trying to feel
good
i washed my hair
so
yeah
you know i think i'm going through some
spaces where i'm kind of
having some new feelings about stuff and
that feel you know i'm trying to see
what that's like
trying to pay attention to my feelings
um
yeah
so kind of maybe where i've always been
but
uh really grateful to be here today with
you guys really grateful that i get to
do this
and i get to spend time with you
um and we get to share things in our
lives that are fun or
interesting or weird
or somebody's weird or our weird
we're lucky
you know we are lucky and uh and i feel
grateful for that
i'm going to be putting some new tour
dates out i'm excited i don't know what
they are yet but i'll probably uh
announce them next week
um
we have the fundraiser for world vision
for ukraine
uh
for relief efforts and it's gonna go i
think a lot of the money specifically
goes to help children
uh so i'm really really excited about
that
and
yeah and if you're struggling with
something man just know that you aren't
alone you know and don't feel alone i
love you
and uh
and just keep going
you know just keep going just get to
lunch get to dinner get to bedtime
uh sometimes we gotta just take the
small steps
um
you know and we take turns one day one
of us has you know is is leading the
other and the next day the other one's
leading the other um
but that's what a gang is baby
that's what a gang gang is
so y'all be good to yourselves bro
uh you deserve it
and i'm off
you know what i'll just finish the song
that we started out with
this is shine by bishop gunn
uh thank you everybody who hit the
hotline 985-664-9503
you guys be good to yourselves man you
deserve it okay
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy
[Music]
built to
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my story
[Music]
[Music]
call my name
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my story
[Music]
i will
find a song i will sing it just
[Music]
yeah baby when we share stuff man it
just
yeah when we share stuff it's good
yeah